in our series profiles in service we
highlight Americans who dedicate their
lives to helping others the New York
City Police Department's elite emergency
service unit is like a SWAT team it
handles a wide range of scenarios from
hostage situations to rescues and
presidential security and detective tina
guerrero is one of the roughly 500
members of the ESU only ten are women
and she is also the only female counter
sniper in the NYPD we recently met up
with Detective Guerrero and joined her
team on a training exercise to the top
of the Brooklyn Bridge from 100 yards
away
detective tina guerrero fires her
remington 724 rifle consistently hitting
her targets how good of a shot are you I
would say I'm pretty good I've heard you
say the ESU is like a big boys
playground and you wanted to play in it
yeah the challenge of just being able to
go out there and do all the things that
all these guys were doing was it was
something that I wanted to do
I did feel that it you know I had to
prove myself as other women do and other
men do to the men and women of the
emergency service unit endure rigorous
training to respond to everything from
search-and-rescues to hazmat situations
and terrorist attacks when I tried out
for the team I was very intimidated but
I said you know go out there and do the
best you can and I did and I remember
getting a phone call from one of the
other guys that I work with and he said
you listen for what it's worth you did
well nice he did well well enough to
trade in her undercover work in the vice
squad for scuba gear and a 50 pound vest
as a member of ESU detective Guerrero
has to prepare for any scenario
including suicidal jumpers we joined the
team on a training exercise there we go
where we climb nearly 280 feet to the
top of the Brooklyn Bridge pulled from
here and you can flip in the team looks
out for each other as we climb the
nearly 6,000 foot suspension bridge that
connects Manhattan and Brooklyn every
time we move we use these carabiners and
essentially were harnessing ourselves so
that we're always safe always tied in I
made it to the top that was pretty
awesome yeah thanks for the great climb
oh you welcome to the welcome this is
like no sweat off your back to do this
no actually I enjoyed every minute of it
it's a great view up here
detective Guerrero's husband is also in
the ESU though the duo rarely worked
together the mother of three works
overnights to spend more time with their
children you've got three kids
you miss a lot of their activities yeah
I have and you put your life on the line
yeah all the time why why do you do it I
do it because I just I just love being
out there I try not to think about you
know the dangers of it there's not a
night goes by that the guys I work with
I know that they're looking out for me
as I do the same for them
detective Guerrero reflects on her
journey to the NYPD's version of SEAL
Team 6 he was actually pretty excited to
come up again and when you first started
climbing or there are some men in the
unit who said I don't think this woman
can do it yeah I believe when I first
came into the unit that I proved a few
people wrong yeah I definitely believe
that yeah they retired now though
retired huh and how did you disprove the
doubters you know because this is a
really rigorous job how do I disprove
that I'm still here you're still doing
it you're still doing it yeah tougher
than ever look I love it I'm out on
patrol every night you don't change it
for the world those days that do change
the world tend to hit her team hard on
911 the NYPD lost 23 officers 14 were in
ESU you're supposed to be downtown on
911 I was just coming back from
maternity
I was on the impression I was supposed
to go to the field that day and actually
I was supposed to go to the truck I know
if I would have went to truck seven in
Brooklyn there's a good chance that I
would have been in the towers a good
chance what a service mean to you
service to be there to be there to be
there to help people you know the great
people of this city you could put your
hand in front of them and they'll follow
you behind to serve this city I tell you
it's really important to me you do it
because you love it oh but it ain't easy
it's not ours time away from your family
and you risked your life every day yeah
yes but it's worth it well worth it well
worth it
she's awesome I mean so great you just
you think about many of those who serve
you know you serve your country in the
military you serve a police department
and what she does and that was that was
easy that was easy for them what we were
in terms of climbing up there you didn't
have to go all the way to the top of a
bridge to interviewer but usually by the
way in icy conditions you know yeah
detective girl she now goes into the
badass category yes very short list but
she's certainly there I'm thinking if
that was me nor I would have needed a
new pair of underwear how'd you do you
know it was a potential dependents
moment as you would say I have to say we
were standing there waiting and I
started to look down and I thought I
said to myself why am I doing this no
Anthony when she came back she said oh
I'm doing a shoot and I'm gonna be
walking the Brooklyn Bridge and I saw
the video I thought I've walked the
Brooklyn Bridge in flip-flops well well
done in Bravo 2 detective Gabriel yeah
he's something else I'll control every
night enemy thank you for it